right now we have the matchup that many
of you are waiting for in the
consolation bracket the final opening
round game it is xqc it is firstly and
we're gonna have liftoff pretty shortly
so let me ask you both last match the
opening round are we just gonna expect
the unexpected at this point I don't
even know what the unexpected is I think
I think it's gonna be fun either way I
think there will be plenty of mistakes
and it's it's it's just gonna be very
enjoyable to watch Ludwig oh sorry it
wasn't my turn to talk so I wasn't
thinking Robert what was the question
Oh who's gonna win something like that
look I asked you if we're gonna expect
the unexpected or do you have any idea
what's about to happen uh on on God
I think xqc you shouldn't have gone live
I think it was a mistake he decided to
do it he's a streamer first he's the
best at streaming I have to admit that
no one puts in the hours that he does
but I don't know the problems xqc is the
problem that most rumors have playing
chess chess is residentsleeper unless
it's fast it just is like it like a
10-minute game if you're just playing
against a random doesn't have stakes
behind it chat doesn't care so you have
to do like three O's you know and then
xqc even more Zoomer just like one O's
and if you're playing those you're not
improving you're just doing what you
already know cuz you don't have time to
think and develop new strategies so I
think the amount of time he's put in is
a lot and I think he has improved but
his on-screen chess time has not been
the most efficient way to play chess and
do we know
hikaru if X you see has also received
some off stream coaching or what Stepan
not as far as I know I certainly have
not had not coached him so maybe he's
looked up some stuff offline but I don't
think he's taken any lessons gotcha well
I was working with firstly last night
and she was very concerned about what if
X you see is working off stream and you
can stream sniping and I think all
players to some extent are worried that
people will know what they're going to
do but she she kind of didn't know what
to expect either and I said that I'm
gonna tell you just play your best stuff
don't wander your pieces work through
your thought process I mean if X you see
do we ever really know
I was he got banned right and then he
had like a 600 rating I remember and
then came back from being banned and had
like an 800 something rating so like he
grinded off stream and clearly you know
put a little more effort into his games
it didn't have to worry about
entertaining chat cuz like he does
always think about what chat is being
entertained not entertained by and he'll
move on very quickly so I think I wish
he was offline right now I think it
would be a much closer game if not a win
uh the fact that he's streaming I'm
nervous for him well Leslie Foose is she
is white in the first game she started
her d4 she loves her party hat in the
London so let's see how X you see who
responds in the very first move
or is he still doing puzzles I yeah
isn't he is not he's doing puzzle he's
crushing the puzzles
let's listen in
I believe it's qcl can I get a new
hoo-ha you Wow
oh and gentlemen good luck BB side may
be so confident that he wanted to give
Bruce Lee a 30-second lead they had
they're gonna restart the game wasn't
aware top of that if TTS is like how is
he supposed to know guys true true
what did I even do here gonna have to
match this right if you say what do i do
on eat I don't like the Queen's pawn
opening at least rush I'm first move I
hate this opening I think
what's he gonna do I don't dilute her he
and I are asking the same questions just
keep on doing at this
if I don't know what to do as black all
I do is mirror them for like the first
eight mm-hmm and I think that usually
works like you can't even know bring
your Bishop to where his bishop is your
night to where that night is in the same
file it's fine it's fine
yeah actually that's a very good
decision to bring this bishop out here
because you get to develop the queenside
fully and then you can push up on e6
without blocking your fishermen at home
so whoa did fousey just make them move
in point four seconds I think I think
she made a pre move yeah oh my god I
know she feels confident her London
system I I don't know moving in point
four seconds is a great idea though
right right get where I excuse T's
coming from because I do hate playing
against the London system because I'm so
much more used to like before or even
like I don't know something something d4
is weird and I hate seeing it but once
you figure out that you can just kind of
mirror you're good mm-hmm okay
okay now he car you coached him so
obviously something you showed him oh
it's on here what's going on here uh he
I didn't I didn't show him this that's
for sure okay but he's gonna be down one
pawn if she takes which I assume she
sees already but this is kind of a
cheese and awakes it's like maybe he
feels he has to do something right away
to go for it and she doesn't take the
pot or what before Oh No see I talked to
fousey about this and oh excuse me
sounded he found it I talked about this
it's when you react you trust your
opponent too much because xec play e5
said oh you know he did it for a reason
but she sometimes thinks a sho blunder
without realizing that her opponent may
also make a mistake so we could tune
into fousey to see her reaction now
because I don't think she's particularly
thrilled oh my god I think of my losses
don't panic don't panic it's fine
you know what you'll take my bishop I
don't need it I didn't want it anyway oh
my god this is terrible
this is terrible okay okay
how did this happen okay what if I just
take him first on the also lose a piece
oh my god he's kind of insane I don't
know I thought oh my god I'm so bad oh
my god what'd I just do oh my god worked
on I can explain this so when he put a
five instead of stopping pausing
thinking about how many pieces she had
attacking the square cuz she the perfect
setup here she freaked out and as she
just said she's panicking so she moved
her Bishop back as a way to not commit
to anything I said she should have
captured on e5 because she has three
pieces attacking it only two defending
and now we see in the game she's losing
a piece but well she lost a piece she
still can fight though because she can
take
she took like this pawn is the best
choice keeping more pieces on the board
she is down now a bishop for one pawn
but Ludwig let's ask you let me ask you
you see this position right yeah white
is clear down material but it doesn't
look so clear does it because there's
still so many pieces on board yeah it's
not that big of a deal I don't know I I
think it's fine like you can come back
from this cuz it's like you don't have a
pawn on e5 as black which sucks white
does and so you know just you got to do
your thing you can still bring out your
knight and ain't that big of a deal like
plus two minus two I think you enough
plunders will happen that that's the
variance you just did yours a little
early what do you think in Gaara yeah I
mean I didn't mean the main problem with
the position is that since I did
originally show foolishly the the London
system is that none of the principles
none of the ideas really apply anymore
like all the basics that that you look
for they're just gone in this position
so that but my main concern is finding
moves that make sense but it applies to
both players because they're not open
lions and so you kind of have to
maneuver your Knights your bishops the
right squares and I don't think this
really suits either player so I think
definitely the game is still very
unclear
for sure and this is a pretty obscure
structure with pawns and f6 and g6 but I
think if you see playing Bishop a5 it
was a great first choice and I wonder if
he'll go Castle queenside because he has
fewer pieces to move out the way to get
his King over there right and the one
thing I would add as well but then this
is I think only X you see that I've
really seen this with but it happens all
the time it says failure to develop
piece all the pieces on the back rank
usually it leaves one side with
undeveloped he doesn't bring out like
the the rook and the nighttime
next to the Queen or he doesn't bring
like the rook the knight next to the
King so this is the the main thing I've
seen is that he has this issue with
bringing all the force into the game but
he plays Bishop d6 which is a great move
for sure and let's listen to xqc to hear
his thoughts what range is good to begin
the +2 and though that I'm forth
embedded on the screen and I can I can
get a long-range castle here I think
you've been in this game because I have
more fun on this side maybe I don't know
I don't know
look check
it's my accommodate today sugar flare
what is that what what is this animal
think about it it's a komodo everyone
sit in wonderful guys thank you
why is that a komodo that's great now it
forces the Talan oh my god oh my god
Luiz traded now his pawns are towered
and the file is opening the gates are
open the gates have officially opened it
sounds like he was gatekeeping there
bing-bang
you need to get it very soon please have
any checks
I've Narcisse it'll be so happy about
stacked pods the rings look at my my
knife into play honestly they're both
playing very just pre moving what is
this
I think the way excuse some plays
actually really difficult I guess here's
the thing and we talked about it a bit
our coaching sessions are basically
two-hour sessions one-hour sessions will
remember eyes a set of 10 possible
openings and it all goes out the window
the moment xqc plays what is it two
pawns straight up on the on the right
side nothing I did matters anymore I
don't know why I'm playing the London
system but I don't know I don't know
what the hell this is what am I supposed
to do here and so it's such a jarring
jarring difference and maybe it's bad
conventionally do you know what you're
doing but the thing is we don't that's
honestly that's a very fair point and
I've taught I try to talk that through
with Bruce Lee last night just say
you're not going to know what's gonna
happen so react to their moves right you
shouldn't just say I'm I had the
strategy and no one you do you should
see what your pawns plan is and she
missed the first one right she missed
that move e5 come me four but since then
she's played very reasonably so she's
actually up over minimum o'clock and
that I think will be very important in
this particular game because it's so
close so
you know Hikaru in this type of position
how do you think that white should
proceed and how do you think Xu C will
be able to handle it if the position
doesn't open up because he is an
aggressive player yeah I mean I think
it's important that she puts her rook on
the C file tries to attack down towards
that night in the pond behind it but
again it's it's a very hard position I
feel like both players we're gonna see
mistakes I think we've not seen the end
of the mistakes they're gonna be
mistakes from both players going forward
simply because nothing is open there no
open files really and with all these
pawns it's just very closed so figuring
out this is where it would have helped
if X you see had done some puzzles or
had had some pattern recognition because
when he needs to do here to try to
checkmate the White King and it's not
easy to come up with ideas to do that
yeah and Ludwig well what are you
thinking about in this position because
we know that black is up a knight for
just one pawn but what would the plans
that you would devise were those B I
mean I think he knows right he knows
that that that files wide open on H I
feel like there's something you can do
there I like it yeah he he's making room
for his knight and he's also I listed
this seems fivehead Haake are you sure
you haven't been giving it's you see
some pointers oh I have it actually I
was also gonna ask his rating is 840
he's improving he's like yeah he was
playing off off stream so I thought his
ring was down like 650 or something so
yeah he was playing off stream done
quite a bit I think you taught him a
secret papaya system or whatever you
guys call it and it's just doing
something that we've never ever prepared
for and it's genius
cuz when he tries doing something like
the scotch we saw what happened when he
does in his own way it turns out to be a
brilliant maneuver yeah but this is a
great move by foolishly setting up a
very dangerous
tactic here if he takes the pawn it wow
he's he's on a wire is that you love
that because now the knight straps
well you can move the knight and then
you lose the pawn Knight guards the pawn
on d4 hmm so you're removing the
defender of that pond because if tonight
doesn't move then you take the night
with your pawn and now you go Knight
takes pawn but I will say the downside
of this putting this pawn here is now
much easier to attack once this Queen
per se retreats a d1
then this pawn is under attack and the
king is feeling a little breezier but it
is a great move he's he's really on his
game right now as he actually loaded
with this is where I would tell you like
when I say perfect moves are not perfect
if I if a grandmaster played this pawn
push and took the pawn
I would say it's perfect but based on
where the ratings are I don't I would
say this is not perfect play because
there is very serious risk to the black
king here so when I do say perfect
usually it's because it's considering
how the quality of the move but also the
danger when you're gaining material so
it's like you're perfect in your own way
sweetie
Wow oh that makes me feel all better
okay cool and Bruce Lee had had a very
good reaction let's listen on xqc sauce
to see well now that he's won a pawn if
he feels like his king is too open or if
he feels like he has everything under
control
yeah and time is important too here we
have xqc
I like I like this better
this is this one's gonna get is gonna
die already
bing bang bing bing bang bing bang and
he gets a free pawn the move here with
him - so poor my problem with it with a
double that slows down my patient I'm
running out of time you guys agree with
his big bang surmise ation more or less
this might have to be supportive that
matter
a straight screen listen she's seen the
same thing we cannot let bigger fools
switch between both streams it's a
different atmosphere shocking Paul he is
showing great supporters that is sweet
whoa what is night a 300 big blunder
incoming
he's thinking in his head right now was
this stupid or brilliant hello he
decided on stupid dress look they're all
supporting each other as one professor
xqc said that as one got taken but I
think it works
professor xqc
[Music]
the one thing we've learned is he loves
that night I mean I think it's good
because like people don't think about
night pins a lot and they come up the
wrong move of the Queen you just get a
free bit and check your check take okay
not gonna do that
check check Moses tapes Spencer that one
to explore
I'm think about it man no Brooke okay
the one downside of the between trade is
what were you saying Robert
end games not easy to win her brains
under attack for brains under back it
seems wishful
this is it I'm evolving just don't
blunder there don't wonder is there
Cherokee doing here
as if you would say no tricks available
I think three minutes is more than it up
I feel like it's very late right it is
time for battle it's a lot of time but
if you trade off too many pieces and the
pawns come off then it will be hard to
win so that's the only thing that I'm
looking at so he he's often trade of
rooks this is great because the rook on
d1 was trying to come to d7 but if you
treat too much and your pawns get off
the board then it's gonna be very
difficult correct although I think the
fact that X you see has brought the last
rook into the game to one piece it was
on its original square I think he should
win this game now the only reason that I
think maybe he won't win this game is if
he blunders one of his knights be
blunders a knight that's really the only
danger that I see here but as long as he
makes relatively quick moves I it's hard
for me to see a way for there to be
tricks that will that kind of like our
real blunders that's that's sort of the
way that I I just don't see it here with
only one work on the board and this
makes it easier for him to write like
foosley you know trading the rooks
mm-hmm so yeah I mean that was the one
thing Ludwig is also like when you're
ahead like you don't even mind if you
make some of these exchange because it
just means your opponent doesn't have
any pieces so like you really can't
tunnel vision when your opponent only
has like one rook or a bishop and at
night because it's only one thing that
you have to worry about like attacking
all your forces yeah my dream is baiting
out a trade for every single piece and
then I can just go through with like my
remaining piece and then like kill all
the younglings you know all the get all
the pawns out of there make my queen
this is what we're talking about with
NIM - I think I think there's no chance
he loses this I'm saying that and I'm
nervous saying it but really I feel like
with this much of an advantage you can
just trade down everything and then
he'll help be able to figure it out with
the time remaining
yeah I think I think he should be able
to I think a lot depends on how quickly
he moves here this is the main dangerous
is getting too long on time good move 92
now well she Seabrooke d1 is another
interesting question too because the
Mennonite can't move right you're just
talking that loudly seeing these night
pins not easy but here rook d1 puts that
night under threat the rook is defending
it but I can't move and that can be
frustrating and she needs to figure out
as well she can play f3 here which
defends her pawn it's under attack and
we actually have her stream up we can
listen in so let us go to Fuu see right
now I don't know if I should move my
rook here oh I should move my rook here
probably to pressure his is that how it
works
keep the pressure on him right right
yeah why am i running i'm attack you
Frick actually that's not very helpful
oh he's like
looks like she's making both moves and
talked about I'm in a bad situation
ecstasy responded really well tonight
time's running down what to do keep
sneaking my pawn by maybe maybe I'll
make it maybe you won't even know what
oh that's fine
I knew that was coming okay so say I go
here right this is where I'll begin
thinking five moves ahead I go here
right he has to move his this right so
he'll like go somewhere else or wherever
right
she important the two that would be very
convenient what maybe I can force him
into a stalemate I think it's very
important she moves fast she's down one
minute on the clock
yeah she's edgy good request to draw
that is that is a clever tactic I think
xqc would be the last person on earth to
ever accept a draw in any position I
think he'd also be the first to
accidentally click it though yeah I feel
like she I've been in this spot she's in
that spot where you're like you're
you're down so much you're nervous you
don't know what to do and all you do is
like you make efforts so for example
when I see a pawn walking towards being
a queen and I'm like two spots away with
my king I follow it even though I can't
get there in time I know that and I know
when it becomes a queen I can't even
enter the zone but I feel hopeless and
powerless like like I must do something
mm-hmm sense yeah it does that makes a
lot of sense actually and actually she
can start by taking one pawn with check
and then taking the second pun over here
and it cards what we were talking
earlier where there were many Queen side
pawns but if you lose two of them over
there that's where it starts becoming
difficult mm-hmm right I still think he
should win this because I don't see how
White's gonna be able to take all the
pawns without losing some of your own
pawns on on be
- an A - but again it's not it's not
it's not over yet and the main issue is
again that she's so far behind on the
clock that uh that I think it's gonna be
very hard for to find these moves
because I think she's panicking a little
bit already she did express that last
night she was like oh excuse he always
just bullet like he's that bullet and I
don't I don't know I can't do that it's
too quick so in time trouble it's gonna
be difficult for she does have the
five-second edit your clock with every
move but I she's not used to it right
exactly yeah I am getting nervous
because I definitely don't think he's
gonna be able to find a mate with just a
rook in two nights
mm-hmm uh at least in the time frame so
yeah I'm gay I'm gay I feel like this is
still fine though suffice he's fine
right he should be fine but it's yeah
it's getting a little bit tricky yeah
and no just reminder to everybody that
no matter what happens this game there
will be a second game so let's say X Q C
does convert this foo C will have a
chance to come back and so it's a two
game match get each color and King e6
with a good mood I'm really worried that
he might go King d5 next move and
blunder rook d7 this is what I'm really
worried about oh good call that's why I
don't like this move at all because
you're going with some of the principles
oh boy I would have done that too yeah
don't say that move no it's a great move
what a great move that would have been
well let us go to xqc right now hear
what he's thinking in this position why
you got this
love that go there it's not the same
though she she found it but she did oh
oh there's this check oh I only saw at
e3 Oh No okay I can just find ology he
does is flabby Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go
Go Go there's no right player
[Music]
I think it's just understanding is one
condition idea shape in Discovery check
my discovery we talked about Queen night
queen night checkmates what asked how do
you do that it's the same way you do
with a king and a queen actually you
just leave the knight far away and then
you just use the king in the Queen
oh so the knight doesn't even matter
right oh yeah that makes sense
hey this is simplest way to think about
it it's just you know how to meet with
the queen and a king yeah you can even
give away your knight and then do what
you would do without it
do we know if he knows how to do that I
think he might and I've definitely never
showing him how to mate with a king and
a queen but you showed him discovered
tactics for the Queen honey check me no
I didn't show many of that I think this
is just this is just off stream that he
that discovered tactic was great yeah
he's really improving he just made it a
lot harder on himself to have to win
like this rather than with rook and
Queen right
I love nervous for him now he's plenty
of time though yeah she got her to draw
scoffing yeah I've never seen him make
that face okay king and queen let's see
if he knows it okay he did it so for
this one what do you go do you guys
college you force it into one of
yes and once the King gets in the corner
you stay away from these two squares
because if your queen is on these
squares and the Kings the corn it's
stalemate so you have to be very careful
okay show this if you see last night
actually okay so the simplest way to do
this and these are a great job is you
want to keep your Queen a nice distance
away from the enemy King except when
it's all the way in the corner as I said
if you have your Queen a nice square way
then it's stalemate because your queen
will take away the remaining squares I
like that it's a very stressful way to
booking a five don't go King a five but
still mate what a game he played - oh
excuse Ino oh my god oh and the song end
is just radio silence I window right try
window light because she was white and
you say Lord when he carves you scene
well I mean the the issue I have with
that is that he gave up the knight and
the only reason you should give up
tonight as if you're a hundred percent
sure you know how to make the checkmate
um and he didn't know he didn't know how
to make the checkmate with the king and
the Queen so that's that's my criticism
is that he should not have given up
tonight unless he was a hundred percent
sure that he could make the checkmate
yeah that's all yeah I will say I know
it's not a natural thing I don't think
to like figure out how the checkmate
works cuz you don't really think in
terms of stalemates and what your
opponent can't do right so I I only kind
of learned recently I do it like like
it's rook King that's the only way I
know how to do it otherwise I'll
stalemate that make sense suit and the
technique from the starting point well I
see was it keeping the night the Queen
and Knights distance away is if the King
goes the side you follow it 1 square
over if the King goes back diagonally
you follow it one towards the Queen side
diagonally if the King comes
diagonally to the right you follow suit
but the one time you stop is right here
because of King to h8 if you bring your
queen here
this King has no more squares and
stalemate mm-hmm so you stop right here
and then you dart your King back to help
to deliver the checkmate cuz why can we
move these pieces here and for all
85,000 Plus you welcome I mean this is
xqc versus fousey now Game two and you
just learn how to check mate with a
queen and a king Gris King yeah yeah a
bit of a shame that he didn't close it
out but I mean he did play really well
the whole game I mean he had enough of
an advantage that he was like plus five
or six at peak so yeah if he gives
himself just in he's gotta give yourself
an easier mate that's it mm-hmm maybe a
pony but you know at least I can do
Queen rook mate yeah I think Queen and
rook most people can do but just the
Queen is certainly harder for sure but
but I think yeah the main thing that I
would say is that he should not have
given up the night unless he was a
hundred percent sure that he knew how to
make the checkmate that was the main
main issue yeah it's and now it's
unfortunately you're in this position
where you're probably kind of
criticizing yourself you're not gonna be
as objective about the game because
you're still beating yourself up over
the first game and right what the great
thing that Foose is done she has played
four openings very quickly and she did
he end up in time trouble in the first
game but she's already up almost a
minute on the clock and we have the
couric on setup here and good move by
xqc
to protect this pawn mm-hmm did you show
her this or not I did look at her go so
what I told her and for everybody
watching is that this Bishop one move
ago if you put your pawn to e6 where you
want to go the bishop gets stuck so you
develop the bishop out and that way you
can play east six with a very strong
pawn structure and everything is safe
and sound at for everybody who's new to
the channel here this is game to whoever
wins this game moves on to the
quarterfinals and through the
semi-finals and not only do they do that
they play Ludwick our lovely commentator
alongside us here
so if this is a draw it goes to the
three oh it goes to a blitz game okay I
understand best of two now you just get
white and black and then we get to the
Blitz and well that should favorite xqc
because he just showed in that last game
he is kind of a speed demon and for
firstly sometimes which she's not sure
of herself she spends quite a bit of
time and here she's doing well though
put her Bishop back on g6 it was under
attack and now her bishops putting
pressure in the center mm-hmm yeah I
think D openings are I don't I don't see
him a lot and I don't like them
so I am mad that you taught this to
foosley and he carved you should have a
moment just later on today if you can
just teach me like that'd be great Wow
okay well also you know I don't say
let's see I don't know what my next move
is it's probably something like pushed
this hot move yeah push this up see so
right now okay he also I realized he
just had to do this he's like if he
castles this way his King side is super
weak so that's like pretty good for us
sure I'm gonna do this finish off my hat
and then I'm gonna do this I might like
to push this pawn as well maybe if the
if so as you can Castle this way
so far looks pretty solid for her yeah I
feel like she's doing what you're
telling her to do but she does not seem
confident doing it well my rule number
one to her was be confident and then the
second rule was just wind forehead so
you know it seems like she's doing some
of those yeah I think she did bring up
good points that it'd be tough to Castle
kingside
if I could predict xqc probably loves
castling queenside because it has an
immediate threat with the rook I like
castling queenside too because of that
so I assume that's probably to prefer to
do if he can even get that Bishop out of
there yeah I was gonna say I noticed his
game against hutch he did push the pawn
him develop the bishop like he did play
b3 Bishop b2 move so if he actually
comes up with that it'll be very hard I
think for for fousey to react to that
because she's C used to getting the
bishop on this d6 square on the start or
at the pond formation around it and then
it's hacking towards the king but here
she's not gonna actually get that
because I assume ecstasy is gonna castle
the other way well the best thing for
fousey about the cap strip we just go
back a move is she doesn't play Knight
of 6 which allows that 'if I push which
we saw in the first game so with the
caps early that tactics out the window
but there's a queen on you too there's a
king 98 so we'll xqc see this pawn
hanging on d5 right oh that's a tough
that's a tough find I don't think that's
too dissimilar of a scale from like
finding a discovered check though now
that what I think is it it depends how
they Castle the Kings have xqc does not
counsel the King Oh excuses a different
animal what is happening this guy's a
beast a same animal different beasts
whatever the phrase is he's onto
something here your your the lit major
here don't rush yourself
yeah that's honestly I love everything
is doing because at the level we're at
things like this get you so much mileage
for sure
pins and discover'd checks are like just
they're so they're so good because
nobody sees them and they'll fall right
into him right very true yeah
yeah I mean I think really the question
is what happens here is who castles
which way I mean I if they both castles
are Kings to the same side which should
be the queen side I think the game will
still still go on for a long time but if
they end up with the Kings not castling
on the opposite side somebody is gonna
be getting checkmated right and the
White King is Sousou saying earlier it's
gonna be hard to Castle especially now
with his rook on h8 staring down here
your rookies need to protect that pawn
but let's listen to xqc and hear his
thoughts about this position he what he
watched sick didn't just take it no what
did the better actually
yeah I think what he did was great but I
feel that sentiment Fett
it seems lazy sometimes and one of the
earliest lessons you guys teach us is
that you know just trading doesn't seem
like the best option all right let me
think about this
not bad what did he do to protect the
Queen you I have to be don't miss supper
don't move we traded Queen trade it hey
Queen trade take it's just so risky this
is so risky you guys so bad she written
anything in like
so nervous today he's spending so much
time just fighting his better judgment
I'm gonna get not even listening to it
gimme gimme me yeah it is just me for
sure
Pink's the center God next move is even
sicker check no I should stand with the
Queen like over here some like that
[Music]
the clock is ticking my pieces are
moving my heart is racing it nobody can
stop me doing I'm already every tire
that's a free night getting is a tough
spot but you can clean it so scary
there's no way
I'm happy to be your rob I'm gonna
employ you
alright I'll play you 725 it's federal
minimum wage you just gotta say hey man
yeah go for that's great okay that works
for me seem like a fair trade now X you
see it's in a similar position last game
right he's just kind of crushing yeah
pretty much
the only issue is again he has to the
one thing that I said earlier still
applies he has to remember to get all
the pieces into the game cuz the [ __ ]
from the rook are still on the Queen
side the [ __ ] from the rook are still
on the original squares that's the only
issue he has here that's right and his
King is a bit unsafe his King will be
safe from Castle queenside but if he
feels like he's guys King out of the
center because like that's what all the
coaches taught me and he goes the King
side that's when this rook and even if
not for the real captain bonheur there's
a lot of open space from the King mm-hmm
whoa oh no that's a free pawn right yeah
that's a lot of material happening here
also the knight here is very good as
well
hitting this Queen threatening this
bishop I think what will seize XGC
trying to force a Queen trade eventually
maybe yeah I think as long as as long as
he moves the knight takes the pawn or
moves it to the c6 square he's gonna
reach an end game where loosely only has
one work or two rooks on the board and
that's very critical that he reached sex
he's using way too much time here so I
think 96 is the move that he should play
and I've seen him hovering over that
square he's been kind of looking at it
but there's one big downside to that
move and because you think of capturing
pieces of if knight c6 Queen to d7 and I
blundered my rook here and then you say
oh I've blown them
other work here this is a moment and I
know it's pretty far down the line where
even though white is up many Brooks to
them this King Ani one is really unsafe
because his Queens coming in with some
checks right exactly yeah I mean 96 is
the is the moves that I I think he
should play but we'll see we'll see what
he's gonna do he's he's using way too
much time here though that's the one
thing I would say that's why I feel like
at this point super critical that he
plays one of those night moves right
away so he's got it he's got to just
trust himself and play Knight to c6
he's also been looking at this Queen
check which is actually very good mm-hmm
if he can find that because then the
knight will capture so if there's a
check on this King the King can't go to
these squares so the King we have to go
to f8 and once the Knight captures us
check to the king and to the Brooke
right I think he's gonna go for it I'm
still worried about his clock though
yeah this Hawk situation is the big
issue here for sure I think the upside
is that he eight does go for it I think
the upside is that even if he does end
up drawing this he has so much upside in
the three oh as well like even if you
like he SL like I figure we keep calling
it right well yeah but the problem is
also I don't think it's gonna be easy
two draws because they're still gonna be
queens and rooks on the board that's
that's why I think it's still very
unclear here in terms of what's gonna
happen because if he had moves a knight
to one of the other squares he would
have been able to get a queen and a
bishop off the board
whereas here he's gonna be giving up a
knight for one rook so black still will
have a queen and a rook on the board
which is more than enough firepower to
create threats and maybe even checkmate
ideas right and Fuu sees she was
thinking about blocking with her Queen
but then she recognized that for white
the knight and the Queen's take care of
that squares of Queenston would be a bad
move and I've seen her hover I hope she
recognized that her King can also move
this does seem tough though what what is
like is there in a crack or sponsors
this is it there's only one movement if
King 2fe only move that's playable here
typical scenario of Zoggs Wang wouldn't
you say she played it Oh
oh wow okay okay so I think Xu C should
be able to win the game now because he
has an extra queen and he's got a lot
he's got bishops and rooks on the board
um so I think he should be able to win
but again we've seen stranger things
happen we certainly have and I really
think she just forgot her kink and moved
because she's so often taught don't move
you're King right get castle so if you
move your King you and her alone castle
so you mix and match different ideas and
unfortunately blunders happen in this
particular moment so let's listen to her
scream to see if she still feel that she
has a chance or unfortunately she feels
like she's defeated here
where are my pieces they are gone okay I
decide actually sees his junk he is just
better than me that during at least
right now I mean like at this moment in
time this happened two games in a row I
just slowly bleed please believe pieces
including my clean so sad this is okay
he's still using too much time so I
don't think it's fine that's true two
and a half minutes counting down he's
using way too much time here this is
maybe I attack his Queen here right
that's not a bad move I guess one of the
big downsides for her as she's saying
her next movie pawn a6 to attack the
queen is that it's all telegraphic why
would you cry on there
oh it's is acting the Queen so he'll
retreat his Queen cavity castles which
is not a good move castles okay fine I
just got him he's just got to move but
again he's tunneling this is sort of
what I'm saying before where he's not
bringing the rook and the bishop into
the game right and you know as we see
here he only has under two minutes
minute 50 seconds coming down yeah there
are some chances for her if she sees in
the future that his pawn to h3 can be
captured and she can swing her other
rook into the guy I mean he's just got
it moved like this is crazy what is he
doing what is he doing it's been funny
he dropped his queen back there good
move to protecting this pawn dunno if he
sees the h3 take what I mean I was
thinking that maybe he's just forgetting
about the time actually I think he might
just be forgetting that he doesn't have
have that much time look that didn't
happen that's not thinking about it papa
Plata I mean the same thing he was
shocked when he lost from time out
true-true yeah well let's listen next
you see in here what are you thinking in
this position where he is up a queen so
I can I can recover
the game every move will be expensive at
the beginning it but once the mat the
mental map is all mapped out it's all
about playing it's not about thinking
it's gonna stop stop moving and please
your knowing
that's a very good play
the time yeah I see thinking too long
yeah I did not proceed it
my needs also works
okay I shall be said something about the
time so I know that he knows about it
take stakes
take steak steak steak steak steak
five seconds to remove REO okay and you
might do it out of the way it might do
it into the final composition and not
lose pieces and move fast
these are my goals isn't my goals this
is my planning these are my goal that I
need to do if I'm gonna do
he seems aware of the time though at
least yeah
don't lose pieces engage all the pieces
derogate start thinking about this to do
that's good move by first either
she confused him but bringing her
what's happening he's getting a little
stressed yes I don't know what's
happening
the lives of this song is throwing me on
a wild ride
come on these moons are so odd
good move now Ricky one is the critical
move well actually see see rook to e1
cuz he was highlighting it before will
he see it as a big question he does see
it he just needs Robert has to be there
going like yeah man you got it yeah well
he's gonna pay me 750 725 come on excuse
me
I that way I would leave you as your
height man to go to him ah I see I see
I'm doing fine so she should take the
pond h3 I'm doing fine problem is I
think Queen takes pawn is too obvious
shoe but I don't know if she'll see
Brooke d6 it's a very difficult move for
treating that work to protect the pond
then move
if she doesn't do anything crazy here -
wasn't insane bang okay there you go
it's oh I don't like this at all
so it's for checkmate in two moves well
he this is this is fat does it move I'd
still get this I get this under I'd get
this 100%
is there a just right here for uh he
cakes though okay for black not really
no but ninety seven check force the King
to the center and it was checked me it
still should be winning but it's easy to
get scared of two rooks barreling down
the h-file towards your king the one
good thing is I don't see if I don't see
a checkmate pattern right so as long as
he moves quickly here he is down to
under ah to move though yeah under fifty
seconds
oh he's in serious time trouble now this
is a good check what's in when the clock
come on
I don't have time to think and I can't
think I'll just go first
you
you've recognized this king was in
danger so he moved it towards the center
where it's more pieces okay I mean now
we're assuming we win together time I'm
only playing the Gemini all you plan to
get a time I'm only gonna play to just
get to get some time get my climb back
up I mean I either was a play and I can
do this this can easy was I can do I
could do I could do this is good takes
takes like you do this
I do take take what is this worth what
else will you do you take take not take
take is even better
moving it's good
take
you call in time I'm gonna be my rock
over here
like this take take take take okay
you know even as more tank okay mm-hmm
yeah I think he can't just you know go
SuperSpeed or whatever it is yeah you
can just move the there's no danger
because they're only rooks on the board
here so unless he allows its tell me he
should be he should let's just get the
pawns out of there man just did a pawn
race there's no point even trying any
anything else
why bother dude just get some time do
the pawn race bing bang bang bang
promote takes takes that's it I want to
worry about anything else a lot to worry
about is this nothing anything this bid
this structure is very good for
everything I'll have to worry about it's
nothing I don't worry about anything
yeah it's go get out showed seriously
good get up throughout today's manage
the great thing is he sees all the
important stuff and then he even sees
the stuff that you wouldn't think of
Mouse like rook taking a pawn and then
dying like he's looking at that I don't
know why he's looking at if running out
of time though she's got to move what a
game both games but we will be right
back in a bit because well when he comes
down we'll have him on for an interview
to hear his thoughts on what was an
absolutely epic performance and we are
back bringing on both firstly and xqc
xqc man what an effort by you you played
phenomenally well all thanks I'm like
what are you been doing how you been
practicing um okay so I feel bad about
this again but I'm going to say shut up
I've been like busy with a lot of stuff
so I haven't taken Icarus lessons but I
watched all of his videos and it streams
we'll have time and a couple tricks I
like the smallest small things like
two or three things I picked up on like
maybe a crazy difference but even a
smart like there's two things he that
maybe made the cruiser Prinz it's moving
the the rooks on the pile to bottom and
end at the bottom unfolding the pawn so
I can I can move my the bishop across
the to the rook and these two things
like make a million more options of the
game yeah and firstly well it was a
tough match for you you did survive that
first game because it's stalemate yeah
did you feel like you had some chances
or did you feel like well on sex you see
was out playing you he was out playing
me I could feel he does he's super agro
and so I kept he would take a piece and
I'd take it like mess of my pawn
position so I was like damn it he do it
again and then again and then I have all
these stack pawns and then I was all I
could think of was lessons that people
were saying like oh you never want your
double Pines double pawns are bad double
so I'm like and then like that that I
just started to crumble so I was hoping
for a stalemate in the first round and
we got it and then the second round yeah
I just I forgot the timer I didn't even
see it
I was like wait how did I made did I win
XQ see I gotta ask you about your
opening cuz it feels like every player
has had a coach and knows the first
eight moves by heart and what you did
confused every person watching what did
you plan your opening or you just
winging it well what I notice is that I
have one of two openings on white but I
have no puddings for black and when I'm
black
I use my I use my board backwards right
toward the gate you know the website
puts my black my position and everything
is inverse I feel like I'm gonna I'm
gonna shrilly I'm like upside down dude
and he makes sense you know I mean it's
not I was just winging it but it's what
the opening was so trash yes you kept
playing D and you just said you had
nothing for that you said nothing for
like a D file opening no I know did you
she kept opening like that like sideways
and Queen spawn what is Queen spun what
is that putting you would even do it
twin spawn I don't to do against that
yeah but it's always good in the way
because the thing is like all of us are
coach to do the first 10 moves and we're
supposed to respond to good moves but
you don't do good moves
you do your own thing that we have no
idea how to respond to because it's it's
no one teaches you
oh yeah he's gonna bring up the b-pawn
then the C pawn that makes no sense yeah
it clearly ended up working out yeah I
noticed what there at the beginning like
I put all my pawns like like planked up
at the top as I did what am I being
going with this man like I know I'm
doing this and I was like if somebody
like if you plan his opener out right it
makes sense but that's what I thought I
thought this makes no sense but if I
doesn't make sense to her either
it amazed no sense no and Bruce Lee
actually at this point here when ecstasy
but II five he had this great idea off
front to win your pieces but if you
counted how many times he's protecting
the scoring five compared to how many
times you're attacking so you could have
taken his pawn here and when he takes
you back you could take again with the
night because your Bishop is here
protecting it i know i tunneled i
couldn't question yes is that what is
that what you do when you put it yeah I
always refrain from doing that except
that was stupid but yeah I tried to
count my times protected like like pawn
tickets one rotates that's too bitter
that's three you count them yeah
you should always you should always be
alert to see how many pieces are
protecting the square okay my sense it
was well played games I every time I
thought I had him I would like okay next
move there's no way and then he'd find a
move that like countered both it like
both possibilities right so I deserve to
lose I mean I have a question for us to
see yep that we had loaded mcgann during
commentary and then I realized that he
was playing the winner of this match so
you play him next so right now you're
all friendly but what do you want to say
to Ludwig a lot is you facing the semi
fun yeah I don't want to make too much
spice okay all right listen
look wig is kind of a friend from high
school who play like 2000 games of
League and he's still silver that that's
kind of how it is so I guess I'll see
you next round did but
if I put a bit more time to listen
you're not making it through with the
time it but I would I would put in a
little side wager I'll gift 100 subs if
you beat me you don't know anything up
yeah Oh easy money Sherman and finally
launched what an Abbott I'm kiddin us in
the book I know your place I've seen
your discovered checks you have great
pins I'm watching out for him though you
know hey guess what my opening is d4 I
only play d4 now okay I'll make I'll
make sure the Nazi before I'm gonna go
through the crazy response that you you
will not foresee and every scripted move
will be absolutely obliterated and
crushed underfoot that's so scary but
I'm gonna be ready for it and when
lesson there's only one when it comes
out of next match buddy oh I'd love to
see it you're a high and mighty look I'm
happy you want a game but let's look at
the record xqc listen I got momentum one
of my good friends always say speed
violence lament tell me a favor I mapped
out winding up I can't beat that if he's
got that on his side that's pretty
that's pretty hard
wait you went from super confident to
now be he's got you by he's got speed
violence and momentum yeah Mutual's a
doctor disrespect on twitter doctor
disrespect is probably better than he
car OHS for being honest for a moment I
have a strategy Robert that I think will
work out he car you uh you teaching X
you see at all if he wants me to I will
yeah yeah car just you know I'll just
slide in your DMS don't worry about
we're gonna talk about but you know just
what do you teach him I'll just be
talking to you right after Ludwig van I
feel a little ignored over here like
Robert look I'm sorry who did you coach
out of curiosity okay don't give me that
no no I'm just wondering who did you
coach that play today was it Wow what
I'm just asking questions I'm sorry I'm
just an interviewer what could I say
look I know Robert you have two lessons
and I'll follow them till I die
confidence and don't say sorry there we
go that's a big part of it but
but I don't want to learn your London
because I don't work for at all Carl
actually taught me that London I'm
hitting up odds Hodges the goat Hans
requital who's slicker and and me baby
in me we're going all the way I've
accepted play xqc I think it'll be
interesting when is it does your a date
yeah not tomorrow with the death of
tomorrow think yeah okay okay okay I all
I remember I have never lost a single
game in any losses break time ever
that's not about a change it never
happened never will
saw Syria and two days when I'll see
them but right thanks for Slee English
and we see in the consolation bracket
now we have xqc taking on Ludwig I think
nobody is rooting for Ludwig anymore I
think he's lost all of his fans just by
he burned bridges are even the field
from the start haven't I haven't I been
the villain from the start it's okay
it's consolation alright hey no one
needs a hero I was doing Batman voices
before the show and now you became the
Joker I'm down for the Joker alright the
the top brackets that's where the heroes
are that's where the that's where like
that the anime Naruto is down here it's
all villains it's all and at the end of
the day we'll see you wins we'll see you
wins I'm just gonna wait I'm gonna let
my play talk all right well in this
bracket how about up top
boy boy versus box box that's a pretty
big matchup there is it all avoid boy in
your opinion I I don't know boy boy box
box is the most interesting one cuz box
box is motivation to enter was playing
boy boy boy boy boy just seems like a
different he's he's a different animal
he's just cut different I feel like he
can read the vorcha keys and then BGM in
like five years if he tried so I don't
know I feel nervous my boy box box but
I'm rooting for box box the whole way
and I think hutch has it on the other
side for sure if car you've heard that
um I mean I think hutch is a big
favorite for sure I think boy boy box
box unless box box is some special prep
creation in advance the match any
sketches voyboy in something I think boy
boy is the big favorite but anything can
happen and and III don't think it's
gonna be smooth sailing the way that
everyone thinks it will be for what I do
expect well I think the most important
question that we have remaining is
between moist critical and slicker okay
that's the matchup all of the semi
finals here at no offense loving and
what do you think between Charlie and
slicker yeah I mean I think I think
charlie is probably the favorite he's
been playing a lot of chest doing a lot
of lessons I think I've seen him
streaming just literally every day for
the last week I think now so he's just
been putting a lot of time in his rate
rating has improved a lot so I think
it's probably the big favor
but slickers probably getting some some
coaching as well so so again you assume
that their favorites but but we'll see
and and so I'm hoping Charlie can win
because then he'll play probably play
Felix in the final there's somebody else
akaru I seen how you play you're
one-trick pony walking around shooting
can't hold it like all the sudden you
think you can start betting on horses
[Laughter]
watch yourself I'm gonna stream sighs
all your ballerina games today could
visit cousin okay okay bring it on bring
it on anyway but yeah I think it's gonna
be great I'm just glad that everybody's
having a good time more than anything so
it's just gonna be great to see the last
couple of match then of course good luck
to you as well a lot like that if I lose
burning bridges yeah everybody just calm
can eat my butt I better win yeah better
way I'm gonna woo I'm expecting to be
hit up later with an apology hey can you
can you help me now but I may say no but
lo we're gonna serious no it's been
really fun having you on for the call
you play xqc next so next time we see
you you'll be a player instead of
Compton I'll see you all Friday and I
think I think any of the forward be hype
but I don't want to lose all right well
we're gonna be checking you out I guess
he cars not gonna be rooting for you but
I'll root for you I got you thanks
Robert thing I guess you meant what I
said earlier man about you being a
history major in that'd be a waste of
time I didn't mean that I think it's
actually so cool key see you
want me to erase the history that we
just had here all this beefing no you
know we're calling to show everybody
thank you so much all you idiot you're
so cool alright yeah no sorry can't hear
much it's great keep going yeah oh it's
so good
don't interrupt me next time then so
yeah it was a pleasure until stop being
a pleasure to have loader being along
for the commentary we will see the
semi-finals next but there may be more
pop champs tomorrow but for now enjoy
the rest of your evening and have a good
one
[Music]